viviamo in un mondo in cui tutto ci
sembra facile accessibile ma soprattutto
dovuto cosa succederebbe secondo voi se
tra 11 anni per esempio nel 2025 acqua
elemento indispensabile per la vita di
ciascun individuo dovesse scarseggiare
come vi sentireste se un giorno vi
obbligassero a calcolare quanta acqua
bere ogni singolo giorno
beh come tutti voi saprete l'acqua è un
elemento indispensabile per la vita e
per l'uomo ma non tutti sanno che sta
via via diminuendo a causa degli abusi
che vengono fatti nei vari settori di
produzione a questo proposito vogliamo
farvi vedere la nostra campagna video se
arriver non arriva
sì insomma con la nostra campagna video
sintetizzavano in tre minuti un concetto
abbastanza esteso che è difficile da
dire in tre secondi ma diciamo più di un
anno fa ci trovavamo in questa in questa
sede in veste di studentesse e dobbiamo
pensare a un progetto che fosse la
conclusione di questi tre anni qui allo
ied
scusate dovevamo creare un progetto che
inglobasse tre tematiche fondamentali
strategie di comunicazione moda e
attualità in un primo momento siamo
state colpite da una notizia ovvero le
nazioni unite hanno dichiarato che il
2013 l'anno dell'acqua nonché l'anno
della cooperazione nel settore idrico
le nazioni unite hanno diverse volte
lanciato segnali d'allarme sulla carenza
idrica ma tali segnali non sembrano
essere stati percepiti nel modo corretto
non sono stati percepiti nel modo
corretto e noi italiani dobbiamo
sentirci toccati da questa notizia
perché l'italia è stata classificata al
terzo posto dopo stati uniti e canada
per spreco d'acqua
dunque come voi vista vi starete
chiedendo come ci siamo posti questa
domanda che in relazione possa avere il
mondo della moda con quello dell'acqua
beh
l'acqua indispensabile per la vita per
l'uomo e per tutto il sistema naturale e
per la produzione alimentare cioè
l'agricoltura ma c'è anche un altro
settore che è quello del tessile che ne
spreca ingenti quantità inutilmente il
cotone infatti che è un materiale molto
utilizzato è il materiale che è stato
classificato come il primo a livello
mondiale per inquinamento a causa dei
pesticidi fertilizzanti chimici che ne
vengono impiegati nella sua coltivazione
inoltre spreca grandi quantità d'acqua
in tutto il ciclo produttivo quindi
parlo dalla coltivazione alla produzione
un esempio scioccante di questo dato è
che un per creare un solo paio di jeans
vengono utilizzati i 9.500 litri d'acqua
quindi potete immaginarvi quanta
utilizzata per la creazione di un'intera
collezione su scala mondiale
quindi noi cosa stiamo cercando di dire
stiamo cercando di offrire una soluzione
che è quella di non utilizzare più il
cotone ebbene se non uso il cotone che
cosa utilizzo cioè una vasta gamma di
materiali classificati water l'ex come
canapa lino bambù eucalitto e poi essere
riciclato che possono facilmente
rimpiazzare il cotone poiché di facile
lavorazione mo dell'abilità poiché non
causano nessun tipo di problema
allergico di altra natura
ma soprattutto perché non sprecano acqua
per farvi un esempio il poliestere è un
l'unico materiale che vi ho citato
sintetico è questo
deriva dalle bottiglie di plastica
quindi già di per sé riciclato si può
riciclare all'infinito e si rigenera
senza mai perdere di qualità l'eucalipto
invece un esempio di materiale naturale
a una resa dieci volte maggiore rispetto
al cotone infatti con sei metri quadri
di piantagioni di eucalipto possono
essere prodotte 10 magliette mentre con
la stessa estensione di terreno può
essere prodotto una sola maglietta di
cotone
quindi cosa abbiamo fatto poi quindi
giusto per noi non è solo un blog
e non è neanche stato un semplice
progetto di tesi per noi è stato un
percorso di scoperte che ci hanno
portato a conoscere ed amare un mondo
che anche per noi fino a poco tempo
prima era un po ignoto ovvero quello
della moda sostenibile
in effetti in italia non è
particolarmente preso in considerazione
ed è proprio per questo che noi abbiamo
creato una campagna di sensibilizzazione
online rivolta al consumatore ovvero
colui che ha il reale potere per poter
cambiare tutte le regole del mercato
l'abbiamo informato circa la green la
crisi idrica aggravata dal settore
produttivo the stile e gli abbiamo dato
un'alternativa
quindi abbiamo cercato di indurlo ad un
acquisto responsabile
etico e soprattutto consapevole senza
però dover rinunciare al design
perché in effetti quello che è il luogo
comune in italia è che la moda
sostenibile sia un po anche estetica nel
processo di ricerca e di analisi che
abbiamo fatto in effetti abbiamo notato
una cosa ovvero che il blog ei siti
internet che generalmente trattano di
tematiche sostenibile di moda
sostenibile non sono particolarmente
curati soprattutto dal punto di vista
estetico
e secondo noi parlando di moda questo
non può succedere perché comunque
l'estetica una certa rilevanza
è per questo che abbiamo creato un blog
che fosse curato dal punto di vista
estetico che avesse una grafica lineare
semplice ma d'impatto ma soprattutto che
avesse anche una selezione di designer
che alla fine potessero rappresentare
quello che è esattamente il lifestyle
sostenibile waterless che noi vogliamo
trasmettere e comunicare al nostro
lettore
in questo caso l'italia che no per
questo studiato per questo abbiamo
spesso e volentieri ci troviamo a
scrivere articoli che trattano di
designer americani piuttosto che i nord
europei proprio perché loro rispetto noi
sono già molto avanti in questo campo e
soprattutto non vedono la moda
sostenibile come una moda antiestetica
bensì come una validissima alternativa
quello che a quella che invece la moda
che purtroppo amiamo ma volte distrugge
questo noi lo facciamo a dimostrazione
del fatto che non solo la moda
sostenibile può esistere ma già esiste
di conseguenza può esistere anche in
italia basta comunicarla nel modo giusto
soprattutto noi riteniamo che un paese
come il nostro che da sempre è stato il
principale punto di riferimento per
tutto il mondo per moda design qualità
made in italy e ricerca di tessuti in
questo caso non possa rimanere indietro
con i tempi ma anzi debba stare
assolutamente al passo rendersi conto
che la sostenibilità in realtà è il
trend del futuro noi sogniamo un mondo
che sia vario che sia fatto di storia di
diversità non un mondo fatto solo di
fast fashion è lì mass market ed è
proprio per questo che anche noi come
tante altre persone che hanno parlato
qui stasera vorremmo che ci fosse un
ritorno a quella che è la artigianalità
che rende unici prodotti l'espressione
creativa e anche la personalità
dell'individuo
noi siamo giovani italiane lavoriamo
anche se in stage ma ma soprattutto
siamo qui a parlare questa sera non solo
perché crediamo nel nostro progetto
fermamente ma perché abbiamo ancora un
po di speranza nel nostro paese e
soprattutto perché noi siamo il futuro
del nostro paese